[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous avez l'impression de
choisir la musique que vous écoutez
les films que vous regardez
est-ce que vous pensez que Netflix
fais de vous deux meilleurs amateurs de
cinéma
ouvre Waze de meilleur navigateur
est-ce que vous pensez
qu'Amazon fait de vous deux meilleur
consommateur
tous les services que je viens d'évoquer
utilise massivement l'intelligence
artificielle du sol au plafond
et que ce soit volontaire ou un
volontaire
systématiquement c'est en réduisant nos
choix
notre capacité d'action et notre libre
arbitre
et pour moi c'est encore plus grave
c'est que c'est service
je ne rentre pas meilleur dans nos
activités
et je pense aujourd'hui qu'il faut pas
la change
alors bien sûr
l'intelligence artificielle Fatim elle
est partout quand on y pense à convoque
des personnages emblématiques comme
Steve Jobs où il y a le cas cocorico
ta convoc décennale sans fiction comme
une heure
et surtout ça convoque la Silicon Valley
avec ses promesses dans un monde
meilleur
moi le premier j'adore intelligence
artificielle
je m'appelle Christophe Rigaud j'ai 41
ans
J'adore développer de logiciel qui m'a
conduit à devenir informaticien puis
cherche intelligence artificielle et
enfin entrepreneur aujourd'hui je suis
très fier de t'avoir confondez diriger
la forge la force d'un start up studio
tu as une mission
démocratiser les meilleures expertise
médicale grâce à Meythet jantes
artificielle
concrètement on accompagne on investit
dans les entreprises pour les aider à
développer des produits tu utilises
intelligence artificielle par exemple on
est des ophtalmo à faire demi-heure
diagnostic il comprit Vendée logique et
des pneumatiques de déserts médicaux on
est aussi c'est mieux que dalle mots à
soigner la cataracte pour que leurs
patients quand il part son utilise plus
net
on travaille aussi aider les médecins à
la médecine préventive
British intelligence artificielle pour
que les individus reste des individus ne
deviennent pas des patients
aujourd'hui j'ai l'occasion et la chance
de vous partager il vous révéler
peut-être qu'il faut moi et la phase
sont de l'intelligence artificielle
Steve Jobs
disait que l'informatique et tu es la
meilleure invention de l'humanité parce
que pour lui c'était comme des vélos
pour l'esprit
moi j'aime beaucoup cette image que
l'informatique en général et
l'intelligence artificielle qui est
débranché plus avancé de lire
permettent aux individus d'aller plus
vite plus loin comme avec le vélo
non aujourd'hui force est de constater
que l'entreprise c'est pas le cas
de constater que quand on utilise
intelligence artificielle
on fait ce que moi j'appelle te calcule
est sous stéroïde
c'est-à-dire qu'on est on utilise
d'intelligence artificielle pour
améliorer ce que font les organisations
elles vont plus vite plus loin par
exemple et je trouve ça génial en un
clic vous pouvez calculer le risque
d'une personne avant de la corde et un
prêt ou pas ou si par exemple je pense
que vous connaissez bien ils sont en un
clic mais moi
ils sont capables de choisir la bonne
vidéo à mettre à la fin d'une autre
vidéo pour être scotché c'est génial
mais je vous défie aujourd'hui on dit
réfléchir après mais à trouver une
application d'intelligence artificielle
qui vous rendent meilleur quand vous
l'utilisez
aujourd'hui pour cette lettre à demain
j'ai envie de proposer une alternative à
ce que l'on fait avec intelligence
artificielle
et cette alternative elle s'articule
autour de trois principes
le premier est évident
maintenant c'est que
il faut se focaliser sur le savoir-faire
si vous partez du principe que vous
voulez créer des vélos pour l'esprit si
vous partez du principe que vous voulez
déporté dans des logiciels avec de l'IRA
savoir faire d'abord il faut les
Antilles fier de quoi on parle
ensuite une fois que vous avez dans tes
pieds savoir-faire vous allez vous en
servir pour identifier les données vous
l'exploiter on vous dit la date à
pétrole de lire mais grâce au
savoir-faire vous allez avoir utiliser
la qu'elle ne pas utiliser et pourquoi
et comment par exemple si vous voulez
travailler sur la gestion
vous prenez les données d'une entreprise
en matière des ressources humaines
trouver des traces de son savoir-faire
en matière de recrutement gestion du
personnel
ensuite ce savoir-faire vous avez
identifié
il va vous permettre de choisir les
technologies d'intelligence artificielle
l'intelligence artificielle c'est un
ensemble de techniques et technologiques
on est ensemble pour simuler des
comportements intelligence il est
l'intelligence l'intelligence là-dedans
prenez l'exemple de l'enceinte connectée
intelligente
reconnaissance vocale ça me fait vocale
grâce au savoir-faire vous avez Danti
fier vous avez donc choisir les bonnes
dates à vous et leur donner du sens de
choisir les bonnes techno par exemple si
vous avez utilisé le machine learning
c'est l'apprentissage machine pour
extraire la aussi des traces du
savoir-faire premier principe il faut se
focaliser sur le savoir-faire c'est
l'alpha et l'oméga les applications de
Lille
deuxième principe je voulais faire des
des vélos pour l'esprit
vous devez des applis vous développer
les applications qui ont pour but de
transférer savoir-faire vous allez dire
c'est simple
Gifi la cité l'utilisateur c'est vrai
c'est ce qu'on fait tous les jours dans
plein de domaines encore faut-il bien le
faire et là je me suggère je propose
trois contrats
la première c'est d'assister sans
infantiliser
infantiliser CK pas de résultat magique
une application qui vous donne un
résultat
expliquer pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas
le banquier de l'incendie chèque et
notamment de l'accordéon crédit sur lui
dis pas pourquoi d'où vient cette note
ça fait pas un meilleur banquier
faut pas infantiliser faut donner les
clés pour comprendre
deuxième contrainte que vous allez
concevoir votre application
assister sans contraindre
il faut que tu sois capable d'assembler
ses outils pour supporter son activité
et donc développer son savoir-faire
ce serait vu qu'on est sur la lettre à
demain ce serait par exemple des GPS ou
vous pouvez donner vos préférences en
terme de conduite
les routes que voulait prendre les
villes que vous voulez éviter
fermer dans un seul visage
dernière contrainte
il faut pas fermer les utilisateurs
prenez l'exemple de smartphone ils sont
bourrés d'application utilise
massivement intelligence artificielle
mais nous empêche de passer une
application à une autre alors que si on
veut développer mon savoir-faire sur
votre meilleur avec l'intelligence
artificielle qui fait qu'on puisse
exploiter tout ce potentiel
et soyons fou ce serait par exemple
passer facilement votre profil de
Spotify Apple Music
d'un service de gestion de vidéo un
autre
aujourd'hui c'est pas possible
si vous avez Danti fier le bon
savoir-faire les dates allez techno que
vous avez l'intention de développer une
application qui va assister dans la
transmission de savoir-faire on arrive
au troisième principe
ce principe
ces deux formes et ce qu'on appelle le
cercle virtuel de lire
est-ce que si vous avez suivi on veut
des portées
dans des algo une part de nos
savoir-faire pour le transmettre aux
utilisateurs pour l'utiliser mais il est
important que les utilisateurs plus
lever le capot et regarder ce qui se
passe
évidemment pour corriger quand il y a
des erreurs ça c'est évident et avec Léa
il y a toujours des horaires comme les
clés demain
mais plus important peut-être
permettre d'ouvrir le capot se permet de
découvrir de nouveaux enseignements
la machine reste bête mais par exemple
on a un projet en ophtalmologie on fait
des diagnostics les diagnostics on part
des signes symptômes facteurs de risque
le médecin diagnostique quand on perd
mais assez praticien de regarder sur le
capot il découvre en fait que la machine
elle a fait des corrélation entre des
signes symptômes la vie
ça devient génial parce que il y a pas
d'intelligence dans les corrélations
comme tu es fait par la machine mais ça
permet aux humains qui utilisent se rend
compte que il y a peut-être des nouveaux
diagnostic et peut-être des nouvelles
maladies
je vous assure par expérience que si
vous mettez en place ces mécanismes pour
former ce cercle vertueux la
complémentarité hommes-machines évidente
si vous appliquez c'est trois principes
se focaliser quel savoir-faire en BD
x design où qu'on soit une application
dans le but de transmettre et sous le
capot on met en place le mécanisme pour
l'utilisateur pour qu'il puisse tirer
les enseignements de ce qui se passe
améliorer le système vous allez faire
des des vélos pour l'esprit
alors bien sûr ça va pas se faire tout
seul
en tout cas je vous conseille pas de le
faire tout seul. Vos compétences nous
entoure et c'est pas si vous connaissez
le développement logiciel mais ça
nécessite plein de compétences là c'est
le moment où je vous donne plein de
bombarder
des producteurs des développeurs des
architectes
comme ça qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'en fait il est important de vous
entourer tous et à Lola
et qu'il comprenne bien
l'importance de ce que vous voulez faire
tu comprennes bien l'importance du
savoir-faire que vous voulez des
multiples de supporter développés ils
comprennent bien aussi le potentiel de
lire
pour que dans le développement du
logiciel parce que développement
logiciel se plaindre micro-choix qu'on
fait en permanence où est-ce que je mets
le bouton qu'est-ce que j'arrive comme
information quel traitement je fais sur
les dates à laquelle je prends ou pas
mais qu'il le fasse en conscience
voilà pourquoi moi je les appelle les
artisans de lire les artisans sont des
individus
qui exercent leur métier comme un art
en conscience en conscience que ce
qu'ils font à une portée plus importante
voilà pourquoi si vous avez Danti fier
une pratique un savoir-faire que vous
avez une fois de plus les bonnes techno
et vous vous identifier des artisans de
lire là vous serez incapable en capacité
près des vélos pour l'esprit
je peux même vous révéler autre chose
vous serez même en capacité d'aller plus
loin vous serez même en capacité de
créer des applications
qui permettront probablement de répondre
aux enjeux de société
que ce soit la crise climatique ou
sanitaire évidemment
et aussi les enjeux d'accès aux soins
démocratisation d'accès aux soins ou à
l'éducation
évidemment les enjeux de justice sociale
mais tous les enjeux qui vous anime
avec
l'intelligence artificielle c'est parti
de la solution pas de problème
alors pour finir ma journée vous faire
travailler et vous demander que vous
vous allez faire avec intelligence
artificielle
toutes les technologies
innovation incroyable
avec l'informatique on a envoyé des gens
dans l'espace on a trouvé des solutions
aux crises sanitaires et rien d'autre
crise
avec Internet
on a créé par exemple Wikipédia
un outil absolument formidable pour
partager avec le plus grand nombre des
savoirs
l'intelligence artificielle
une chose est sûre si vous m'avez suivi
c'est que
nous devons tous être acteur
pour répondre à ces enjeux
si on veut que les générations futures
regarde dans le rétro et 10 avril cette
génération là ils ont développé des
choses qui sont réellement un progrès
humaniste ils ont développé avec cette
technologie des nouveaux services
tu nous rende meilleur
alors peut-être que la
vous poser la question moi je sais pas
quoi faire avec intelligence
artificielle
c'est pas grave
le conseil que je peux vous donner qui
est empirique c'est que si vous parlez
autour de vous de vos idées de vos
savoir-faire si vous partagez ce qui
vous anime
autour des enjeux de notre société et
autres
je suis convaincu qu'autour de vous des
artisans de Lia se révéleront des gens
qui viendront adhérer à votre idée
la rendre concrète pour tous une chose
est sûre en conclusion
c'est la balle
et aussi dans votre camp
à vous de jouer
je te remercie pour l'attention
[Musique]